when welcome to this video playing our
glass from the US ok is playing the and
exchange variation on v6 everybody
nowadays knows that this line the ball -
variation is interesting
including my opponent so let's see how
it continues from here an interesting
position for sure so I'm going to try to
play Bishop before next and trade Auto G
form g4 is probably easier should before
you might have some alternative here I
just know that I get to track the bishop
for absolute absolutely certain no black
that is to take there to play six and
then a d7 f5 ideally okay
so okay I don't know if D Phi this is
all that effective Knight a5 to c4 can
be interesting
yeah I'm not really threatening to take
their ever as always
okay yeah I was thinking 95 to have
night c4g
prevents okay so let's go over there
seam seam no thinking your trust to put
more pressure on the night but I don't
really see how so
okay I'm here if I take and push should
age six that's a bit annoying there to
put it mildly what is what is what
what's this move now rook d3 airplane
nights you form yeah this is a check
check
[Music]
really
check quite resigned
okay I think that I'm testing out this
opening at the moment it it works quite
well alec eyes people don't seem to know
anything special against it and I mean
literals are who's really okay can't be
formed that it did all feels very
natural and here why must be okay but
somehow here things got quite tricky
already here here lab should be three as
suggested by the comp this already is
the problem
here's a good way to cover it I mean
would be three I was actually thinking
here might give one a 6m like it's a lot
better is already better special making
edge to it is basically gifting it away
oh he resigned Fox already heck didn't
really think about this it just looks
too too bad but this isn't all that
clear my night is still hanging Andrew
cage one interesting so g5 mmm-hmm
[Music]
okay that completely bonkers both my
pieces are hanging but I have this and
winds Wow so the resignation was
completely unjustified the Queen f6 is
actually stronger in this position yeah
this is better now
okay yeah they're soaking in three okay
but I can't Queen h4 and really can't
cannot really a question myself they're
too much that's weird the weird weird
resource yeah but never resign yeah it
seems there was still it was still
completely unclear thanks for watching